[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing some time ago
some years ago
there was a man called damar nakshwani
and this was and still probably is even
though he's not been active
the main spokesperson or public speaker
for the shiite community he started to
become more and more aggressive towards
sunnis when he
started to insinuate that the companions
or the roots of all terrorism uh
isis-type terrorism originates at the
time of the companions obviously this is
a kind of sectarian
bias uh because of the fact that he's a
shi'i and obviously shiites
for the most part have a negative
attitude towards the companions
having said this now after he said that
he said
he made a challenge he said he came out
and he said i'll do if you
if you want to debate me on this issue
then uh
that i'm happy to debate you know i'm
going to conceal my faith you want to
debate me
come and debate me i won't conceal my
faith one [__] with
along and actually accepted that
challenge so that hassan shimrani
a specialist an ex-gi a specialist in
shiite studies
who's been researching this topic for
about 15 years
and then of nowhere we've seen that this
individual
has put his tail between his legs and
ran away and we haven't heard anything
from him
until until quite recently when he was
on a podcast
denying that he ever said anything about
accepting a debate challenge
before let's see what he has to say i
remember someone messaged me
a few years ago and they said to me
that you challenged anyone
for a debate and here's the clip from
your lecture
which was the lecture on the roots of
terrorism and radicalism
and i was certain that in that lecture i
never ever challenged anyone to a debate
they said no no hey here here's the clip
there's nothing in the lecture on you
know on radicalism
or radical islam which says that there
was a part
of a lecture on shia
sunni marriages and in there i was
discussing how
you don't need to be apologetic with the
future spouse
be ready and say listen you want to
debate i'm ready to debate
because this is marriage this is the
decision you're going to make for life
they took that part out so as you guys
can see here
he denies that he ever accepted the
debate challenge in the first place
but if you listen to the the context
before and after
this particular debate challenge was
made
this is what he has to say let's take a
look i won't conceal my faith one [__]
with you and i'll tell you exactly what
i think
others in pakistan in place like quetta
and places like para
others pakistan
and quetta
so quite clearly here if putting it in
context
the guy is lying through his teeth
to try and avoid debating and it's fine
the fact that your cowardice has been
made
obviously clear for all to see suddenly
shiite muslim and non-muslim
is enough of a victory for us but i'll
end this very short video
with one comment it's ironic that you
are the same individual
oh say that uh amar
that was accusing amar mulchhattab
from fleeing in cowardice in the
battlefield
because it seems like the only one who's
free fleeing
from the intellectual battle for the
intellectual battlefield
is you wash
you